يشير الإرهاق هذا الشعور
بالإرهاق الكامل ودراسة جديدة إلى أن
أولئك الذين تنفجر طاقتهم دائمًا قد
يكونون أكثر عرضة للإصابة بالرجفان
الأذيني المعروف أيضًا باسم الألياف أو الرجفان الأذيني
وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، وهو
اضطراب ضربات القلب الأكثر شيوعًا
والسبب الرئيسي للسكتة الدماغية في  نحن  في عام
2017 ، قالت الوكالة إن الشذوذ هو
السبب الأساسي للوفاة في أكثر من
26000 شخص ، تابع الباحثون أكثر
من 11000 رجل وامرأة بدون الرجفان الأذيني
على مدى أكثر من 20 عامًا
وقارنوا النتائج مع أولئك الذين
أصيبوا بالمرض في نفس الفترة الزمنية.  يشير
البحث المنشور في المجلة الأوروبية
لأمراض القلب الوقائية
إلى أن الإجهاد المزمن والإرهاق
يمكن أن يكون عاملاً رئيسياً في تطور
المرض ، فلماذا الصلة المحتملة
بين الاثنين بينما هذه مجرد
دراسة أولية يشير أحد الباحثين
إلى أن الإرهاق الحيوي
مرتبط بزيادة الالتهاب و
زيادة تنشيط استجابة الجسم
الفسيولوجية للضغط والتي يمكن أن
تضر أنسجة القلب وربما تؤدي
إلى تطور الرجفان الأذيني في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا ماندي جاثر